[Music]
imagine a world without fish without
fishing communities the bountiful
harvests of the sea have provided so
much to so many for so long fish and
fishing have gone hand in hand with
culture with prosperity with the very
roots of civilization
ever since the birth of humanity our
ocean has helped feed us
it has helped us stay healthy fish
consumption around the world has more
than doubled in the last 50 years but
for many it is far more than a healthy
supplement to their diet one in ten
people depend on seafood for their
livelihoods for 1 billion people largely
from developing countries seafood is the
primary source of animal protein
but our ocean has its limits
ever-growing demand means ever-growing
pressure on dwindling stocks population
growth and environmental degradation
will make the problem worse action must
be taken so that stocks are fished
sustainably
we must do allocate illegal unreported
and unregulated fishing accounting for
15% of the world's catch a global
response is needed to clamp down on
those who don't play by the rules
hope also comes from aquaculture
we already eat more fish from
aquaculture than from wild fisheries
like our ancestors on land we are moving
from hunting to follow whilst strict
environmental standards must be met
aquaculture can help meet the growing
demand for seafood so what will we do
together to ensure that fisheries are
sustainably managed that the aquaculture
sector grows responsibly and that the
futures of fish and fishing communities
are secured
[Music]
you